[Music]
i does anybody know tennis players
yeah i know people who like tennis
serena williams no djokovicovich isn't
he isn't he the uh like the top dude
yeah he's like the top g top guy i know
roger federer just did a collab with
ronnie five for kiff andre agassi wow
business guy
do you guys play your cup tennis never i
don't know let's play bro you know what
you know what is fun though go on
youtube you just watch top tennis
freakouts
where people just go
or they'll like go to the uh you know
the high chair just bash the bottom of
it like a [ __ ] tree they're trying to
cut down or when like tennis balls like
hit birds and stuff and they birds die i
saw one where this guy like threw a
water bottle and it hit the guy sitting
up top or something like that and then
and then the guy up top is like hey man
you hit me you could have hit me or
something and he's like no i don't know
what he's talking about
he's like he's opening he's like no you
could have him he's like no no i don't
know what you're talking about dude i
didn't do that he's like yeah nope the
guy you're talking about that's nick
curios oh [ __ ] and he's the one who kept
saying it flew out of my hand he blew it
at me yeah yeah that's what it was
he says it like [ __ ] over and he
chucked it right and he really did throw
it but he was like no i was trying to
drink a flu out of my own day
so that's the guy nick curious is who
we're going to talk about right now uh
curiosity was playing in the finals of
wimbledon 2022 against djokovic right at
the finals it's not going well for him
he gets mad at somebody in the stands
that's distracting the [ __ ] out of him
and he's like talking to the uh what's
called the chair on fire he's like yo
she just keeps [ __ ] talking to me the
middle of the match kick her out blah
blah what's she saying is she heckling
yeah but isn't that a part of the game
like in all sports where you're just
like hey [ __ ] you
you don't do that intense oh they should
they'd be more fun you don't do that you
get kicked out for doing that so it's a
classy sport he was saying um he started
saying yeah she's drunk out of her mind
and then um i'm gonna show you a video
that real quick
because it's really funny what happened
is this girl who's yelling
she ends up getting kicked out
all right
but it turns out
she's a lawyer daughter oh i thought
she's like the daughter of a king or
something but is she drunk nigerian
prince
is she mean she is pretty mean but um
it doesn't matter man you gotta be mean
to be a lawyer you know damn if she's a
lawyer she's like the super karen i know
my rights too
that's dangerous oh wait there's no
video for so basically he gets her
kicked out
he says this word for word he goes uh
he goes she's drunk out of her mind and
he and the uh chair empire goes which
one is it he goes the one that looks
like she's had about 700 drinks man
like
kind of like it's kind of embarrassing
to be saying that about her yeah turns
out she's a lawyer
now she's suing for defamation
what yeah but was she drunk
and does it matter she's like i didn't
have 700 drinks though it doesn't matter
because she thinks that because when he
was saying that stuff it was televised
it was caught on camera so now she's
like oh that caused irreparable damage
because she's a lawyer
dude that's such [ __ ]
i don't like either of these people
that's why i love ron artest
if you could have a guy that's just on
the court and just goes right into the
stand just pops someone in the face yeah
and then changes his name to [ __ ]
world peace yeah
elbows [ __ ] yeah yeah
that clip is so crazy where are your
elbow [ __ ] james dude i was at that
game were you really
yeah did i mention bro i'm in like 300's
right the whole crowd's going crazy it's
[ __ ] double over time this full
[ __ ] elbow is james harden and you
already know all the lakers like boom
that's [ __ ] right [ __ ] slow-mo
comes up on the scoreboard or on the on
the big-ass box and everybody just gets
mad silence
clearly this one is like oh
it's [ __ ] funny dude
jake started just walking he doesn't
even know what's happening
dude this lady sucks
yeah isn't that crazy that lady sucks i
can't believe that's even allowed that
lady sucks but so does he huh well she
so the thing is i was like oh maybe that
seems kind of severe but that's kind of
what happens all the time so like
whenever a tennis player is being
distracted they actually have the power
to stop the game and go
get him out of there like i can't play
okay that's tight that's not just tennis
so like that happened uh in basketball
too right it happens in golf too doesn't
it yeah yeah golf is speaking the
funniest thing just happened to a rory
mcelroy uh on in the fedex championship
or something like that a dude walks up
to the [ __ ] green right and and rory
macro is like a four-time like pga
champion right dude walks up to the
green puts a ball on the green and it's
a remote control ball and it's just
[ __ ] rolling around
so everybody's like is this live golf no
this is a pga tour this is an actual
championship so everybody's like what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] face
kevin mcallister roy at first he tries
to push it away with his putter right
he's trying to get it out and then he
keeps on going back and then literally
he's like looking at the dude who's
controlling he picks up the [ __ ] ball
and he chucks it into the lake and
everybody starts to shoot good hell yeah
[ __ ] funny dude here's the
interaction here
there's not a bigger occasion he didn't
believe me
[Laughter]
which one is it
so this type of moment is super not
unique like you this and this dude kind
of does this a lot is this in america or
the uk or i believe wimbledon is
probably in the uk wimbledon he's
awesome but he's but it's the wimbledon
finals final so yeah there's a lot at
stake yeah so he's like dude i can't
serve in the finals she's [ __ ]
distracting me there's a there's a big
crowd so she must have been really loud
and obnoxious to be able to like
still
like
[ __ ] project uh her voice or whatever
from like the hundreds of people that
are because because when you watch a
tennis match you can it's so quiet you
can just hear that
and like the pop people are really quiet
here he he lost that right did he lose
that he lost it because it hurt man so i
think he already lost so he loses and i
think the the judge should throw the
[ __ ] lawsuit out
and then both of them lose everybody
lost and should get run over by a car or
something yeah yeah can he swoop back to
being like i lost because of your ass
heckling me i don't know i don't know
double suit dude
counter shoot no it's called doubles oh
sorry my back though i learned that in
the johnny depp uh amber
i was watching so like
for that being such a common thing the
reason i'm saying that is because uh
it's uncommon for people who are being
kicked out to have a lawsuit for
defamation did she win
it's it's just got filed
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude so this
this happened a little bit a little bit
ago and so the news of her suing him for
defamation is what's currently on the
plate but doesn't that make her look
even worse yeah but to lawyers do they
give a [ __ ] there's no money i don't
care
especially someone rich they consume and
then also on those things too right
half of those half those legal battles
aren't even like about getting the money
sometimes it's about just drowning
somebody you know what i mean in the
[ __ ] uh legalities of the time the
paperwork and the stress oh yeah until
until they settle that's habeas corpus
that's what she's saying which makes it
very obvious is because she's like until
nick curios provides some form of
resolution i will be moving forward with
my lawsuit an apology which is like a
soft way of saying hey let's do a deal
mm-hmm i don't know what you get
what about an apology yeah that's
honestly that might do it and he goes
but if you don't want that then
obviously you want money it could be
yeah dude people are digging something
for it because obviously she thinks it
affected her life in some way and caused
her disease you ain't that important
dude it's because she she said she
wasn't drunk that's the thing she's like
i and she she said she had like one cup
of rose and like some other thing and
it's like she's not drunk but she's
[ __ ] she's [ __ ]
uh excuse me
i just have a bad personality i actually
don't drink
and she's mad
i'm just [ __ ]
i'm just that [ __ ]
so who knows how that's gonna turn out
it's
obviously everybody hates this lady for
doing is there a picture of her but also
get your head in the game bro
[ __ ] [ __ ] just just see what she
looks like i want to see what she looks
like no no no because then then we're
going to be off camera off camera
we're not that important
700 drinks come on let's we're going to
call her a [ __ ] then we can't show her
face i don't know what you're talking
about dude but we said it before we saw
what she looked like okay cool let's see
if she just works okay
if she's hot you have to admit it though
yep you have to raise your hand if
you're still down to banger regardless
never mind oh a thousand percent i'll
never
see you're already raising your [ __ ]
surrogate arm circuit
it does look like a like a
that looks like him
oh
she looks drunk dude dude her eyes her
eyes are like this she looks drunk
she's she's british or maybe that's uh
no she's polished but she looks like oh
food
she's drinking her lawyer's gonna be
like they caught my client mid bling
i feel like they put vodka in that she
looks like she's annoying bro she looks
annoying right she does gotta look at
noise some people look annoying yeah
some people just wanna to be fair though
he also looks annoying he is annoying
dude
a lot of people he kind of i think a lot
of the top tennis people kind of have
that uh thing where you know people are
just like oh there he goes again he
sounds like you know he sounds like a
cry baby dude when i saw him throw that
water bottle he's like i didn't do it i
didn't i was like dude you suck
you suck bro how come we don't see
female tennis players [ __ ] acting up
oh you do oh you do okay you go to that
compilation of times they freak out
there's this one girl it didn't say her
name but she got so pissed she went over
to like well like i said you know the
the chair umpires on that high-ass seat
she went over to it like at the end of
the match was like shake hands whatever
she goes up to with a racket and just
starts chopping the [ __ ] out of the
bottom
like making holes like the things gonna
[ __ ] tip over and he's like hey what
the [ __ ]
chill out but she does it in total
silence and after like several chops she
just like walks away i'm ready to play i
saw one clip and this was actually a
very heartwarming clip it was on
sportscenter and it was a tennis player
he threw up the ball he served or
something trying to ace whoever he was
playing against and i hit the ball girl
and the ball oh yeah and he went over
and i gave her a hug and i was like
that's so sweet
he's a kicker out she's distracted yeah
yeah get her out of here
she's drunk
where a dude lost his [ __ ] and like
because he was like running and he
missed the ball so he got pissed and
there was like a little uh like a little
advertisement sign that's on the ground
like standing up like this so he got man
he kicked it and he didn't know that a
guy was sitting on the other side of it
and he broke through it and kicked the
guy in his leg
he did the peter griffin
and the dude's leg was bleeding oh [ __ ]
because he like got so pissed and all he
could see was a sign like this and he
kicked it through
straight through i think tennis has to
probably be one of the most boring
sports though nah tennis is
spicing it up with some rage hey tennis
is lit but wait i mean when they're like
acting up getting all mad like this on
my bro you're playing tennis bro chill
out
oh [ __ ]
i thought it was a gentleman's sport
you